the devaluation of lebanon's currency
has made life difficult for many anger
is growing more than three years into an
economic crisis that shows no sign of
improving
in the past international support
focused on the more than one million
Syrian refugees in the country the
highest number of refugees per capita in
the world
that's changed the European union now
says 2.2 million Lebanese need financial
assistance that's more than a third of
the population
the blocks commissioner for crisis
management announced additional funding
during a visit to Beirut but made clear
it won't be enough to resolve the
challenges
a 20 increase
compared to last year
but
as you know humanitarian Aid
is
not
a sustainable long-term solution
this continues reforms this continues
political consolidation
this continues election of a president
this country needs a government with
full powers in place
and this country needs an agreement with
the International Community
specifically with international monetary
fund
the envoy reiterated the international
community's long-standing position the
financial Lifeline needed to rescue the
economy is through a deal with the
international monetary fund
political leaders have refused to
cooperate because that would entail
losing influence over the state's
resources instead some officials blame
the presence of Syrian refugees for the
crisis
the authorities of Lebanon of their own
responsibility for providing basic
services to the citizens of Lebanon
and let me be very clear the current
crisis
of in Lebanon in financial terms in
inflation was not caused by Syrian
refugees
International Aid is at least for now
holding off lebanon's transition into a
failed state but already the policy of
no policy making has impacted all
aspects of life including and all but
paralyzed public sector Beirut